madame monsieur bonsoir voici les titres
de l'actualité de ce vendredi 24 août
deux anti inflammatoires en question ils
pourraient provoquer des accidents
cardiaques
il s'agit du celebrex et du vioxx
utilisé dans le traitement des
rhumatismes et de l'arthrose
les pv moins cher grâce à l'euro pour
avoir un compte rond les amants seront
toutes diminué
cinq ans après la mort de sophie toscan
du plantier le suspect numéro un a été
interpellé par la justice irlandaise
peut-être enfants va-t-on connaître la
vérité
les têtes couronnées d'europe ont rendez
vous demain à la cathédrale de sow pour
le mariage du prince héritier de norvège
hier sa jeune fiancée roturière s'est
expliqué sur son passé peu conforme aux
traditions du gotha mais d'abord une
très belle histoire celle d'une
naissance dans des conditions tout à
fait particulière la maman linda trente
trois ans atteinte depuis l'enfance de
mucoviscidose
l'iscid aux n'a dû sa survie qu'à une
double greffe foie poumon il y a trois
ans après cette première réussite
médicale
elle vient d'accoucher par césarienne
une petite fille mano qui se porte
parfaitement bien la guérison de la
maman et la naissance de cette petite
fille souligne s'il en était besoin
l'importance des dons d'organes encore
trop rare en france
explication cécile delarue avec nos
confrères de france 3 nantes et la maman
et le bébé se portent bien
manon 2 kg 4 et 46 cm manon un petit
miracle pour sa maman qui ne croyaient
plus il ya trois ans linda m'imaginais
même pas avoir un enfant
atteinte de mucoviscidose elle ne
pouvait plus respirer ni marché avant
qu'une greffe des poumons et du foie
minuit sauve la vie jamais fait ça
représente tout ce que j'ai ce que j'ai
fait pour en arriver là
j'ai lutté pour l'avoir docker et
détermination oui je suis quelqu'un on
ne serait pas là je pense vous être une
première médicale
donner la vie après une double greffe
reste exceptionnel est encore risqué
pour la mer la grossesse c'est un risque
supplémentaire après une transplantation
c'est indiscutable et je crois que les
jeunes femmes qui le souhaitent sont
informés de ce risque
après c'est à elles à prendre la
décision nous ce qu'on pense c'est qu'à
distance de la transplantation c'est à
dire plus de deux ans après une
transplantation pulmonaire
c'est envisageable avec des conditions
de sécurité
tout à fait raisonnable maintenant on ne
le sait pas encore mais pour qu'elle
voie le jour sa mère a couru un risque
supplémentaire de rejet plus mones
melinda n'a pas hésité par quinze jours
le don d'organes lui a permis de
renaître
elle a choisi à son tour de donner la
vie de nouvelles craintes liées à la
prise de médicaments cette fois c'est
d'anti inflammatoires dont il s'agit le
celebrex et le vioxx largement utilisé
depuis un an pour le traitement des
rhumatismes et de l'arthrose pourrait
entraîner des incidents
cardiovasculaires
une étude américaine met en garde contre
les effets secondaires de cette nouvelle
génération d'anti-inflammatoires jean
daniel flaysakier et delphine horvilleur
avec jean-françois chevet vioxx et
celebrex sont deux médicaments à la mode
par rapport aux anti-inflammatoires
classique que l'on voit ici ils sont
censés être peu agressif pour l'estomac
et apaiser les douleurs
on se les arrache d'ailleurs comme des
petits pains quand c'est arrivé en
france les patients l'attendaient déjà
certains avaient déjà acheté à
l'étranger
les médecins les ont beaucoup prescrit
utilisé d'abord dans la polyarthrite
puis ensuite pour les douleur
arthrosique
ils sont donnés à des millions de
patients à travers le monde et avec le
succès viennent les effets secondaires
parfois inattendus ainsi la revue
médicale américaine jama attire
aujourd'hui l'attention des médecins sur
un risque faiblement majoré d'accidents
cardiaques chez les utilisateurs de ces
produits
cette étude ne permet pas à elle seule
d'affirmer la réalité du risque mais
pour les spécialistes il faut informer
les patients de cette possibilité d'
accident je pense qu'il faut donner une
information aux gens qui sont traitées
pour une maladie coronarienne
il faut bien leur dire que ce médicament
comporte une petite interrogation sur la
possibilité d'aggraver leur maladie
coronarienne et dans l'ensemble chez les
sujets
ag ce sont des médicaments à manière à
tous beaucoup de retenue il n'y a pas de
médicaments miracles il y à des
médicaments efficaces mais l'efficacité
va souvent de pair avec des
inconvénients dont il faut que médecins
et utilisateurs soient bien conscients
après le conseil des ministres de
rentrée hier à l'elysée le premier
ministre lionel jospin a réuni son
gouvernement à matignon pour un
séminaire de travail
on y est abordé tous les grands
chantiers de l'année y compris les
sujets qui fâchent comme la réouverture
du tunnel du mont blanc aux poids lourds
le ministre vert yves cochet s'était
prononcée contre ce qui avait provoqué
quelques piques de la part du ministre
des transports jean claude gayssot
d'aînés jospin est intervenu dans ce
débat filet boisserie et dominique
bonnet yves cochet a laissé son vélo
devant matignon puis il a traversé la
cour à pied une façon de montrer qu'il
est écologiste convaincu même si
jean-claude gayssot le soupçonner fière
d'être un peu trop vert dans le
gouvernement
les coups de griffes aujourd'hui oublié
le gouvernement tient à se montrer
certes combatif mais néanmoins pacifique
voyons se renier le jour de la saint
barthélemy irak al kurd a confiance dans
l'unité de la gauche d'une gauche
plurielle rompu à l'exercice de la
rentrée puisque c'est la cinquième et
dernière avant les prochaines élections
si chacun affiche son style le ministre
de l'intérieur lui rappelle l'objectif
il faut dire que les dossiers ne
manquent pas de la corse à l'insécurité
en passant par le ralentissement de la
croissance laurent fabius a d'ailleurs
mis en garde face au dérapage des
finances publiques
tous les sujets ont été abordés et puis
bon je crois que nous sommes très
conscients des blagues du moment
la sécurité 35 heures l'euro toute une
série de problèmes qui ont été évoquées
par les agrumes je crois que le
gouvernement est à la fois je répète
serein lucide aussi décidé à traiter ces
problèmes mais elle reste donc la
polémique sur le tunnel du mont blanc
sa réouverture est confirmé tout comme
la concertation qui doit l'accompagner
visiblement les esprits se sont calmés
et rapprochés on se dit ce qu'on a à se
dire mais avec un souci justement
d'efficacité de cohérence qui ne recule
pas d'ailleurs sympathie l'amitié que
nous partageons de son côté le ministre
de l'environnement ne fait plus de la
faire un casus belli
bref on n'aurait pu fumer le calumet de
la paix si yves cochet n'avait pas eu
une meilleure idée je vais offrir un
stylo montblanc mes produits sont en
triant le courrier accumulé dans la
boîte aux lettres pendant les vacances
vous allez sans doute retrouvé une
lettre du trésor public
c'est l'avis d'imposition pour les
revenus de lance de mille et une fois
n'est pas coutume elle contient
peut-être une bonne nouvelle prime pour
l'emploi et diminution des barèmes
claudine gilbert et claude marques ont
calculé à qui profite le plus ces
baisses la feuille d'impôts dans la
boîte à lettres feu n'est jamais une
partie de plaisir pourtant bonnes
surprises cette année
ce contribuable va payer 1000 4 francs
de moins que l'an passé
ça me fait quand même assez d'argent
pour pouvoir faire un peu plus de sport
cette année j'en suis très content au
total le cadeau fiscal du gouvernement
s'élève à 32 milliards de francs pour
que cela se sache votre avis
d'imposition souligne clairement la
réduction ici par exemple 1456 francs
autre nouveauté la prime pour l'emploi
une prime destinée aux plus bas revenus
exemple un célibataire qui gagne six
mille francs par mois
il aurait dû payer 850 francs d'impôts
mais grâce au 1250 francs de la prime
pour l'emploi il encaissera un chèque de
400 francs l'opération est bien plus
intéressante pour un couple sans enfant
avec un revenu de 35 mille francs ils
bénéficient d'une réduction d'impôt de
4300 francs selon certains syndicats on
est loin de la justice fiscale c'est une
mesure qui s'applique uniquement à l'apu
sont revenus et qui fondamentalement
pas l'inégalité globale du système et
irait même par rapport à l'impôt selon
revenus elle profite surtout à ceux qui
en payent et surtout à ceux qui en
payent beaucoup avec la prime pour
l'emploi 8 milliards de francs vont être
redistribués à comparer aux 23 milliards
de réductions d'impôts accordées aux
plus hauts revenus et aux classes
moyennes un signal clair à quelques mois
des échéances électorales
et comme un bonheur n'arrive jamais seul
le passage à l'euro va faire baisser les
amendes l'état décidé d'arrondir au
centime nférieure les pv 11 euros pour
dépassement du temps au parc m soit 72
française au lieu de 75 francs peggy
leroy et julie aprilia pour les détails
un bébé c'est une mauvaise nouvelle à
partir du 1er janvier 2002 la soupe et
sera toujours aussi désagréable sauf
qu'elle saura en euros mais au fait
combien coûte en euros une contravention
pour avoir occupé une place réservée aux
livraisons euros il est à 6 francs
quelques bonbons on peut faire ça cette
fraude et centimes supérieure 7
soit 2 14 pas facile à
explications une amende de 75 francs se
transformera en pv à 11 euros
c'est-à-dire 72 francs et 16 centimes
une économie de presque 3 francs la
conversion est moins juteuse pour 230
francs d'amendé qui font 35 euros
c'est-à-dire 229 francs et 58 centimes
en revanche pour les 450 francs 68 euros
ne font que 446 francs et 5 centimes
grâce à la monnaie unique
pvi contravention pénales seront donc
légèrement moins lourdes
en revanche pour un délit plus grave si
vous ne payez pas vos amendes le temps
de prison restera le même il ya cinq ans
en irlande sophie toscan du plantier
épouse du célèbre producteur français
étaient assassinés dans des conditions
sordides
aujourd'hui le suspect numéro 1 vient
d'être arrêté par la police irlandaise
alors qu'il tentait de prendre l'avion
pour londres
sa compagne qui était son principal
alibi dans la sphère vient en effet de
porter plainte contre lui pour coups et
blessures et one by lait doit
comparaître aujourd'hui devant le
tribunal correspondance and pour signer
si ian bailey a été arrêté cette semaine
c'est que sa compagne a porté plainte
contre lui pour violences conjugales
a priori rien à voir avec la sphère
toscan du plantier dans laquelle yann
baye laye fait figure de suspect numéro
un depuis cinq ans pourtant cette
dernière arrestation pourrait bien avoir
sur l' enquête des répercussions
considérables et ferment à 96 à l'époque
sophie toscan du plantier venait souvent
dans sa maison de skull en irlande
jusqu'à ce jour de décembre où l'on
retrouve son corps devant chez elles
portant des traces de lui les soupçons
se concentrent rapidement sur ian bailey
journaliste occasionnels qui habitent à
proximité et apparaît le lendemain du
meurtre le visage griffé un journaliste
qui ironie du sort rend compte de la
sphère dans les journaux arrêtés et
interrogés bayley dénonce l'attitude des
enquêteurs les policiers m'ont bien fait
sentir qu'il pensait que c'était moi le
coupable et que tôt ou tard ils réussir
à le prouver mais baylet a un alibi sa
compagne elle affirme qu'il n'a pas
quitté la maison cette nuit là or cette
femme vient de porter plainte pour coups
et blessures contre bègles est peut-être
reviendra-t-elle cinq ans plus tard sur
son alibi
peut-être est-ce aussi ce cas craint
bayley puisqu'il a été arrêté alors
qu'il essayait de quitter l'irlande les
hypothèses que la police tentera de
confirmer les enquêteurs ont une semaine
de ventes eux car conformément à la
décision de justice rendue cet après
midi yann b les doigts jusqu'à vendredi
prochain rester en prison ou sous strict
contrôle judiciaire s'il parvient à
rassembler la caution qu'on lui demande
incroyable course-poursuite effectué en
france par la police suisse après avoir
bien pris en chasse un bal un jeune
français soupçonnés de vol la police us
l'a poursuivie jusqu'en france et l'a
abattu dans sa voiture au moment de
l'interpellation
entendu par la préfecture du haut rhin
les policiers helvétiques ont fait
valoir un droit de poursuite pour avoir
pénétré sur le territoire français a
expliqué qu'ils ont agi en état de
légitime défense ils sont toujours en
garde à vue
olivier caroff la fusillade a eu lieu à
quelques mètres seulement de la
frontière franco suisse
il était une heure ce matin sur cette
route venant de suisse
une voiture volée lancés à ses trousses
une patrouille de la police helvétique
pour arrêter le voleur
les policiers suisses sont entrés en
territoire français et ils ont tiré
tuant sur le coup le conducteur l'homme
un français de 27 ans connu pour divers
méfaits n'était pas seul à bord en plein
milieu de la nuit j'ai été réveillés par
les sirènes de police et juste après
j'ai entendu mais j'ai regretté horrible
j'ai vu une femme sortir de la voiture
elle pleurait hurler qu'on les rende son
bébé qui était à bord la femme et
l'enfant indemne mais très choqué ont
passé la journée à l'hôpital
sur place les policiers français ont
commencé leur enquête sur cette tragique
course poursuite
les trois policiers suisses ont été
placés en garde à vue interrogé par
leurs collègues français il nie avoir
commis une bavure il invoque la légitime
défense et le droit de poursuite qui
leur permettrait de franchir la
frontière
la nuit dernière en israël nova
l'incursion de l'armée en territoires
autonomes palestiniens pour la première
fois depuis quatre ans et dans la ville
palestinienne d'hébron comme les
israéliens ont mené leur opération
militaire pendant ce raid de trois
heures sans l'adimad dynamité deux
maisons
affirmant que ces habitations étaient
utilisés par des tireurs prenant pour
cible une colonie juive située en
contrebas sur place
nos envoyés spéciaux agnès vahramian et
jean-françois renouf la fierté nationale
palestinienne brandis sur les ruines de
la nuit nous sommes ici à hébron dans la
partie sous administration palestinienne
en face l'autre colline est sous
contrôle israélien
c'est là-bas que vivent 400 colons juifs
au milieu des 120 mille arabes que
comptait bros hier soir pour détruire à
l'explosif ces deux maisons vides depuis
des mois les israéliens sont venus en
six parties de leurs bases militaires
ils ont traversé ce quartier palestinien
abou sneneh j'ai pensé que c'était la
guerre parce qu'il y avait beaucoup de
militaires et d'armement j'ai surtout
pensé qu'il ne partirait pas sans
laisser de morts ou de blessés
derrière cette incursion a suivi de peu
un tir de sniper palestiniens hier soir
le tir a blessé gravement un enfant de
la colonie alors qu'il était sur son
balcon
une fois entrés dans hébron côté
palestinien l'armée israélienne a essuyé
des tirs de kalachnikov jusqu'à 3 heures
du matin
sur le trajet des véhicules blindés les
maisons palestiniennes
les habitants terrés l'autre nuit
racontent qu'ils ont essuyé des tirs de
militaires
les israéliens ont demandé à mon père
d'ouvrir la porte
mais on a eu peur qu'ils nous tirent
dessus alors on a refusé et c'est là
qu'ils ont ouvert le feu les enfants
dorment est là et le père affirme qu'il
n'y avait pas de tireurs palestiniens
celle qui tire c'est ceux qui sont
recherchés par israël et qui n'ont rien
à perdre mais nous on n'a rien à voir
avec ces tirs
hier soir l'opération coup de poing
israélienne se voulait avant tout un
avertissement
ces incursions après des tirs
palestiniens se multiplient mais à
hébron c'est la première fois depuis
quatre ans ce matin un porte parole de
l'armée israélienne
expliqué que s'il le fallait saâles
reviendrai et cette fois resterait
nouveau coup de filet au pays basque
espagnol six membres présumés de l'êta
ont été arrêtés en catalogne par la
garde civile qui a saisi 200 kg
d'explosifs il ya deux jours déjà près
de san sebastien la police basque avait
démantelé un commando vincent nguyen
la police espagnole ne boude pas son
plaisir et c'est avec fierté qu'elle
offre à la presse les images de son
succès une opération sans bavure menée
dans quatre appartements de barcelone et
surtout un nouveau coup infligé à
l'organisation séparatiste eta
les armes ont été saisies ainsi que plus
de 250 kilos d'explosifs dérobée il ya
six mois en france à grenoble et pleven
assurément cet arsenal était destinée à
tuer prochainement
parmi les six personnes arrêtées
aujourd'hui figuraient trois membres
fichiers de letea est particulièrement
fernando garcia rôdera il est considéré
comme l'un des auteurs de quatre
assassinats perpétrés à la fin de
l'année dernière
deux conseillers municipaux du parti au
pouvoir
un ex ministre de la santé et un
policier
le thé avait entamé il ya plusieurs
semaines une campagne d'attentats contre
les intérêts touristiques espagnole sur
la côte méditerranéenne
mais ce soir l'organisation séparatiste
apparaît affaibli par les coups de
boutoir d'un juge déterminé baltasar
garzon et par l'accord de coopération
conclu entre les forces de police du
gouvernement central et des autorités
régionales basques en moins de trois
jours deux commandes auront été
démantelé plus de 430 5 kg d'explosif
saisie tandis que le numéro 3 de letea
était extradé de france et écroué devant
les caméras décidément satisfaite de la
police espagnole encore cet après midi
vers 14 heures une maison d'habitation a
explosé les voisins ont entendu trois
déflagrations
selon les premières investigations il ne
s'agit pas d'un accident mais d'un acte
délibéré trois charges d'explosifs
auraient été retrouvées difficile de
savoir pour l'heure le motif de cet
attentat qui vient en tout cas renforcer
le climat de violence qui sévit depuis 8
jours / ligne sur place nos envoyés
spéciaux olivier théron et vers gia
d'eau 15h30 cet après midi à une dizaine
de kilomètres au nord de bastia
trois explosions l'arrière de cette
maison est complètement soufflée
heureusement il n'y aura pas de victimes
pompiers gendarmes arrivent rapidement
pour mettre en sécurité ce qui reste du
bâtiment
le constat des démineurs après une
rapide enquête éclair il ne s'agit pas
d'un accident
le procureur de la république venu sur
les lieux le confirme
la seule hypothèse d' accident serait
une émanation de gaz or la vérification
de la chaufferie exclu en l'état cette
origine
par contre on trouve à l'intérieur d'une
des pièces de l'appartement une
expiration et un effet de souffle à la
fois vers le bas et vers le haut qui
paraît faire penser à une substance
explosive posée à l'intérieur une fois
le type d'explosif déterminer l'enquète
s'intéressera au propriétaire de la
maison qui est aussi directeur d'un
restaurant
dernier indice le mode opératoire
particulièrement dangereux qui consiste
à faire exploser une maison en plein
jour au bord d'une route très fréquentée
depuis hier des trains spéciaux sont
affrétés pour approvisionner en euros
les départements français nous vous
l'avons montré et voici maintenant le
voyage but
l'intérieur avec les policiers d'élite
spécialement formés depuis un an et des
dizaines de milliers de pièces dans
chaque wagon qui donne à ces convois des
allures de trains postaux audrey goutard
surveillance au sol et protection venu
du ciel l'hélicoptère sur le chargement
d euros des tonnes de pièces protégées
par des policiers sur les dents des
précautions sont immenses l'itinéraire
emprunté reste secret même pour ses
hommes un satellite surveille en
permanence le train qui traverse
lentement l'est de la france
autour les blindés de l'armée de terre
ont été déployés près à contrer les
attaques surprises depuis des mois
policiers et militaires sont formés
spécifiquement à l'intervention en
milieu ferroviaire et selon les
autorités ils sont fraises à affronter
toute éventualité
l'imagination des malfaiteurs est sans
limite
je dirais que nous avons essayé quand
même l'imaginer tous les scénarii
possibles
et que nous avons mis en place des
systèmes de sécurité qui sont censées
répondre à tous tout type d'agression
d'ici à la fin novembre des centaines de
trains comme celui ci vont sillonner le
pays
puis ce sera au tour des billets plus
léger que les pièces ils seront
vraisemblablement transportés par la
route ou par avion
mais là encore c'est une opération top
secret
calais attire de plus en plus de
britanniques depuis l'ouverture du
tunnel sous la manche pas seulement pour
le charme de son site mais surtout pour
les immenses magasins qui vendent au
plus bas prix tous les produits
fortement axé en grande bretagne à
commencer par l'alcool ce commerce
florissant suscite d'autres convoitises
les voitures immatriculées outre manche
dont les coffres sont remplis de
marchandises sont régulièrement
fracturée au point que la municipalité a
dû ouvrir des parkings surveillés
reportage frédéric vion et dominique
maes
contrairement aux apparences nous ne
sommes pas en grande bretagne on est
bien en france à quelques kilomètres du
centre de calais ces magasins sont des
cash and carry littéralement payer et
prendre et si les prix sont en libre et
les panneaux en anglais c'est que la
clientèle est ici presque exclusivement
britannique
de ce côté ci de la manche
de nombreux produits sont en effet bien
moins cher qu'en angleterre d alcool à
la lessive en passant par les cigarettes
les prix peuvent varier du simple au
double ses parents et ses 200 cigarettes
en angleterre moore a coûté au moins 45
livres 150 francs oui en fait c'est
moitié prix mais dans les rues de calais
ces touristes ne se contente pas
toujours hélas de profiter des prix à la
française certains doivent aussi
découvrir la police française chargés à
ras bord de marchandises leurs voitures
sont des proies faciles pour les voleurs
résultat 20 % des plaintes pour vol à la
roulotte émane de britanniques
pas toujours très prudent il est vrai
n'est pas rare qu'ils déposent qu'il
laisse dans leur véhicule
des objets tels que les caméscopes des
téléphones portables voire de la george
de l'argent liquide en grande quantité
en sommes sortis pour le vrai cross ce
matin nous avons trouvé notre voiture
cambriolé et celle de côté aussi
ils ont pris ma part qu'à et celle de ma
femme qui en plus était tout neuf est
jamais servi et de l'alcool ou du tabac
donc ça ils l'ont laissé pour informer
les automobilistes de ces dangers la
ville fait distribuer chaque jour des
tracts bilingue rappelant quelques
règles de prudence
mieux encore depuis deux ans bonjour
monsieur sarr d'insécurité on est là le
touriste d'outre-manche ou d'ailleurs se
voit même proposer l'accès en plein
centre ville
un parking gardé et gratuit il s'agit
pour calais de rassurer ses 30 millions
de visiteurs britanniques annuel qui
laisse chacun dans l'économie locale
une moyenne de 500 francs
et moins de place pour les voitures des
couloirs plus larges pour les autobus
la nouvelle municipalité parisienne
entend favoriser le transport en commun
au détriment des automobilistes le maire
bertrand delanoë se dit ouvert à la
concertation mais estime la mesure
nécessaire
en dépit de la polémique que cela peut
susciter
jérôme soûlard et souffir motif à paris
en voiture les problèmes de circulation
les bouchons et les retards
ce n'est vraiment pas une nouveauté mais
depuis quelques temps c'est vrai les bus
et surtout les vélos ont retrouvé un peu
d'air on a toute la place il n'y a pas
beaucoup de buts donc ça va le muret est
infranchissable élargi cette nouvelle
voie de circulation est réservée aux bus
et aux vélos 7 km réalisé 35 d'ici la
fin de l'année circulation aisée pour
les ans problème pour les autres
j'entends normal qu'on n'y avait pas
face à la livraison
voilà le bus voilà vélo taxi et non
aller dans la merde
le dossier bien sûr et délicat malgré la
polémique le maire de paris lui n'a pas
changé d'avis c'est un problème de santé
publique grave des parisiens en
particulier les plus faibles les enfants
les personnes âgées
les personnes cardiaques et que tout ça
est dû à la pollution et tout le monde
sait que la pollution à paris en tout
cas elle est d'origine automobile
pour bah voilà l'objectif est clair
encourager les parisiens à emprunter les
transports en commun début ce que l'on
espère ici plus rapide
les premières conséquences vont être une
amélioration très significatif de la
vitesse commerciale ce qui va améliorer
la régularité et donc ça veut dire que
nous transporte est plus sûre pour nos
voyageurs des bus peut être plus rapide
mais pas plus nombreux pour l'instant
sur les routes
les parisiens vont devoir encore
patienter une circulation fluide dans la
capitale
ce n'est vraiment pas pour demain les
automobilistes en tout cas sont priées
de réduire leur vitesse de 20 km/heure
au mieux de laisser la voiture au garage
pour diminuer la pollution
aujourd'hui elle a dépassé le seuil
d'alert il devrait en être de même
demain et pas seulement à paris
strasbourg et marseille ne seront pas
épargnés
sophie mais elle est olivier robert fait
peur ce matin
paris s'est réveillé dans la purée de
pois le scénario n'est pas nouveau il
finirait même par lasser du soleil de la
chaleur est pas un souffle devant la
pollution à l'ozone adorent ça
d'ailleurs depuis le début de l'été en
ile-de-france le seuil dit d'information
a été franchie qu'un soit autour de
paris et six fois à paris intra muros
coupable à plus de 80% les gaz
d'échappement automobile pour limiter la
6e' la préfecture de police a sorti sa
carte habituelle
la réduction de la vitesse des véhicules
de 20 km heure pour toute cette journée
de vendredi
cela a un effet certes mais marginal car
contrairement aux idées reçues
si aucun parisien de prenait sa voiture
aujourd'hui
quand même une position assez importante
c'est tout à fait juste
effectivement si on arrêtait
complètement les émissions de
l'agglomération parisienne
on arriverait au mieux à déminer d'une
soixantaine de microgrammes les niveaux
d'ozone tout à fait parce que la
position et la lnv voyage cette fois ci
c'est une pollution à l'échelle
continentale à strasbourg pour
encourager la population à oublier sa
voiture et transports en commun ont fait
un effort un seul ticket payer 10 francs
pour voyager toute la journée dans la
ville les bus et les trams sont aussi un
tir plus nombreux à rouler pour
l'occasion quand je vois qu'il fait
chaud contrat j'essaie de prendre le
tram et la voiture région de marseille à
proximité de l'étang de berre cette fois
ci c'est l'activité industrielle en plus
du trafic routier qui responsable d'un
nuage d'ozone qui a tendance à migrer
une pollution qui est générée autour de
l'étang de berre peut très bien montée
avignon c'est ce qui se passera
aujourd'hui on a avant qui vient du sud
donc on sait très bien que la pollution
générée autour de l'étang de berre
montra du côté d'avignon
demain samedi ce ne sera toujours pas le
jour idéal pour les vélos la canicule va
aggraver le niveau de pollution
l'amélioration ce sera pour dimanche des
orages devraient la baie le ciel chaleur
pollution est un peu trop de sport
pendant le week-end un cocktail qui
favorise l'accident cardiaque selon une
étude récente menée au chu de toulouse
les infarctus sont plus nombreux le
samedi et le dimanche chez les hommes
âgés de 54 ans 20 % de décès
supplémentaires par rapport aux autres
jours de la semaine
alors ne forcez pas trop sur activité
physique juliette meurin et david bres
on dit souvent qu'il faut faire du sport
pour éviter les accidents
cardiovasculaires l'activité physique
limite les risques
mais elle peut aussi provoquer
l'infarctus c'est ce qui est arrivé à
jean yves dupuis la traditionnelle
randonnée du week end s'est terminé aux
urgences
ben eager est passé à côté on va faire
j'ai pas encore si dur que ça encore
quelques années vous avez quel âge
quarante neuf ans et je pensais à tout
sauf à faire le professeur ferrière est
moins surpris par ce genre d'accident
les infarctus sont plus fréquents le
week end parce qu'on ne fait pas de
sport régulièrement ce constat permettra
de faire un peu plus de prévention avec
des conseils simples
faites attention n'allez pas faire un
trekking très exigeants ça peut être
dangereux pose à l'exception si vous
êtes sportif
si vous êtes un très bon état ya pas de
problème mais si vous avez des facteurs
de risque il faut peut-être faire le
poids votre médecin généraliste et
indiscuté pour aller plus loin calculez
vos risques vraiment même fortune faire
du sport donc mais pas n'importe comment
il faut un juste milieu dominique 2
humeur lui ne faisait aucune activité
physique il a dû s'y mettre
comme au sport je fais essentiellement
de la marche les gens faut au minimum
une heure par jour alors quelques fois
une demi-heure matin une demi heure le
soir de dépenser de temps que j'ai pour
la faire trouver du temps pour éviter
l'infarctus
rappelons qu'en france les accidents
cardio vasculaires sont la première
cause de décès ils n'en croient pas
leurs yeux et pourtant ils y sont
l'amérique ils ont rêvé le secours
populaire et le ministre de la recherche
ont fait 22 enfants étaient sélectionnés
pour visiter cap canaveral en floride
alors que 5000 autres nous vous les
montrerons hier passer la journée sur
les côtes normandes à ouistreham
ces 22 l'art accompagné par l'astronaute
français philippe perrin avait vraiment
la tête dans les étoiles
reportage sur place de notre
correspondante isabelle bechler 1
partira et un pâtir b on va aller
visiter un des deux malheureusement il
n'y a pas d'excusés et enfin jeudi il
n'y a pas de navette spatiale
qu'ils soient parce qu'aujourd'hui ils
ont 12 ou 13 ans et normalement ne
devait pas partir en vacances cet été
les voilà ébloui malgré le décalage
horaire à parcourir le kennedy center de
la nasa avec un véritable astronautes
comme guide
ici le pas de tir de la navette
américaine c'est le saint des saints de
l'aventuré spatiale qui l'ont approché
et décoder un peu grâce à philippe
perrin à un tiers défense de petits
français qui partent en vacances je pas
au 20e siècle
c'est quand même quelque chose qu'on
essaye de combattre qui est anormal bien
sûr qu'il ya une injustice sociale
1 voilà regarde envoyé comme ça crame
est là
philippe perrin x ingénieur pilote de
chasse décès enfin astronautes à la nasa
représente ce chemin professionnel et
social que la science permet peut-être
plus que les lettres la science comme
outil d'intégration même quand on n'a
pas la culture où l'argent c'est
possible selon lui ça me fait un peu
penser à star wars
les modules qui voudra y ait jamais vu
vraiment je voulais être qu'il allait
jouer la sphère privée de chance
puis devant une maquette de la navette à
bord de laquelle il va aller dans
l'espace en avril 2002 l'astronaute
pédagogue rappelle son credo c'est des
vacances mais je crois que derrière il
ya des choses très sérieuses qui
pourront pas se dessiner pour pour eux
de faire carrière dans des métiers
d'ingénieurs je tiens à qui veulent être
footballeur c'est de les convaincre de
comme ingénieur on y arrivera
aujourd'hui la science demain dit
sereine en faut pour tous les goûts
tirage au sort pour le premier tour de
la coupe de l'uefa aujourd'hui à monaco
les cinq clubs français engagés s'en
sortent plutôt bien attention toutefois
strasbourg match délicat contre le
standard de liège et le paris saint
germain sera face au rapid de bucarest
je vous laisse regarder le panneau pour
sedan troyes et bordeaux qui rencontrent
des équipes disons moins prestigieuses
bernard tapie a décidément du mal à
trouver un entraîneur qui lui
conviennent josé anigo vient d'être
congédié c'est le deuxième qu'elle
remercie en quatre mois deux hommes
assureront l'intérim il s'agit de
skoblar et de lévis prochain match
samedi face à bastia mariage princier
demain en norvège
le fils aîné du roi va épouser dans la
cathédrale d'oslo
une jeune roturière de 28 ans mère
célibataire d'un petit garçon de 4 ans
celle qui est appelée à devenir reine de
norvège s'est expliqué lors d'une
conférence de presse sur son passé
disons tumultueux sa confession a
conquis le coeur de ses futurs sujets
mette-marit c'est son nom et le prince
héritier haakon la noce paul de genève
spécialiste du gotha européen
avis de beau temps sur la famille royale
norvégienne et pourtant cette jeune
femme a bien failli provoquer une
véritable tempête
tout avait bien commencé sa rencontre
avec le prince a con héritier de la
couronne de norvège leurs fiançailles le
couple et merveilles le royaume ses
origines modestes séduisent elle fasse
noël être la famille royale et son fils
marius née d'une précédente relation
la reine est comblé le tableau est
parfait enfin pas tout à fait rave party
& drug la presse des terres le sulfureux
passé de la future reine l'opinion
s'inquiète
y aurait-il quelque chose de pourri
aussi au royaume de norvège
et pour couronner le tout son ex-petite
amie a été condamné pour violence et
trafic de cocaïne
la monarchie tremble sur ses bases
conférence de presse à deux jours de son
mariage la jeune fiancée se confesse
j'ai vécu des expériences que j'ai
chèrement payée afin qu'il n'y ait aucun
doute sur ma position aujourd'hui je
tiens saisir cette occasion pour
condamner la drogue
mission accomplie les norvégiens lui
pardonne le portrait des tourtereaux
peut retrouver sa place dans les
vitrines dos nu la fiancée de nouveau
fréquentable
les têtes couronnées affluent de toute
l'europe une dernière photo de famille
avant le grand jour
heureuse cendrillon a conquis son
royaume et son beau père elles sont
absolument snob définitivement non
conformiste et franchement égoïste mais
aussi follement drôle
les héroïnes abfab absolutely fabulous
pour les initiés débarque sur les écrans
dans une version française
josiane balasko et nathalie baye
reprennent les rôles titres de cette
série culte britannique qui racontre qui
raconte l'amitié entre deux femmes qui
ont tout essayé dans les années 70 et
continue à vivre comme elles l'entendent
marie-jo jour de l'autre carrière
demande ou sur rendez vous sur rendez
vous sur rendez vous on n'est pas les
admins des nouvelles du jour c'est
l'équivalent féminin des affreux jojo
ce qui me fait du bien ne veux pas de
mal pour les autres et les autres de
façon avec 18 ans fera pas justice côté
un verre d'eau avec du caviar dessus
quand une femme ne veulent plus
chérissons et seuls ceux qui y restent
mai 68 ça marque après avoir fait route
stocks et brûlé leur soutien-gorge patty
est dit on continue à refuser en bloc
marie éducation des enfants et cuisine
ces deux fashion victim quinquagénaire
bonnes affaires la vie à coups de coupes
de champagne et du mouv h
j'adore dialogue alambiqué quelques-uns
sont signées pierre palmade clin d'oeil
sur un milieu du branché acteurs dans
leur propre rôle
le film de gabriel aghion et surtout
l'occasion de découvrir deux actifs hors
d'elle même
nathalie baye opère ici un radical
changement de registre
méconnaissable en nymphomane et s'il
faut s'écouter
c'est génial deux interprètes et patti
elle est tellement démentent tout est
démesuré et tout et tout et tout et plus
qu' il faut toujours aller au delà de ce
qu'on a naturellement envie de faire
parce que j'avais naturellement envie de
faire et après je me suis abandonnée je
me suis amusé quant à josiane balasko
je me suis allé préciser qu'elle est ici
comme un poisson dans l'eau mais on est
peut-être un petit peu moins burné quand
il s'agit devaient patrouiller dans les
quartiers chauds quelque part mes
proches puisque je la joue alors je sais
comme fatigue on est obligé pour mais
bien obligé de trouver en soi ce qu'on
va jouer alors mais sinon dans la vie et
vos chansons dieu merci entourage je ne
ressemble pas à un duo absolument
fabuleux ces deux là sont aussi déjanté
et nous rien à envier à leurs consoeurs
de la série culte britannique qui savent
qu'on mangera n'importe quoi et on
s'applique sans papiers se termine ce
journal dans quelques instants la météo
avec isabelle martinet le point road
valérie maurice 20h50 soirée polar avec
deux épisodes de pj une heure le dernier
journal présenté par laurence piquet
quant à moi je vous retrouve demain à
13h excellente soirée sur france 2
bonsoir